the Joe Rogan experience how about Elon
Musk that crazy [ __ ] and shot a
[ __ ] Tesla up in the space yesterday
with a mannequin on board singing it
David although it wasn't people on board
no Manik yo I thought there was no
people dude sitting in a Tesla Roadster
that's like a mannequin like it looks
like a dude and he's there that's what
it looks like yeah is this live right
now you could see it yeah that songs on
a billion time loop it's gonna play for
a bit how does he have the battery
different now for this song to keep
playing he's got some Sun and he's lying
he's lying
these batteries run out of this goat you
could go 248 miles that car runs out of
gas
dude I thought he said actual [ __ ]
Rockets yeah there was an actual rocket
and the Tesla Roadster with a mannequin
and it was attached to the rocket so at
the very apex of this rocket as you know
there's multistage Rockets they popped
this [ __ ] out and it goes flying
through space he shot a [ __ ] car into
space like imagine aliens coming to
Earth and they said and this is like the
first thing they finally what the [ __ ]
is this is that a person no no there's a
the richest craziest guy one of the
richest craziest guys on earth one of
the smartest guys he just launches cars
into space for a goof like these people
are [ __ ] you see a lot of rich
people that maybe say these what are you
sure they just want to get richer sell
the right thing just dude how much money
is he blowing on this [ __ ] that's this
is made on earth by humans yes I think
you blew a hundred million dollars to do
this click on that link of the the image
of the Tesla with the earth behind it
yeah I mean that is just what a crazy
image that I want to hear I never talked
to Eddie about that I want to hear his
real theory on that Eddie Bravo don't
talk to about it I want to hear it it'll
change the way you think it's got to
change now there's whole new of this
going no it doesn't it's not based in
reality man it's not based in logic or
reason it's because he has no logic
behind it he wants to think the Earth's
flat he's like you don't know he doesn't
trust science doesn't trust scientist
doesn't trust anybody I mean I get that
but you got to have some logic still to
back
you know what one of the things that
makes Eddie so good at jujitsu is he has
an idea to get a move on you and he's
[ __ ] completely locked on that idea
and everything that's trying to shut
that down is just like he needs to come
up with a defense for that he's gonna
find a way that's how he looks at ideas
as well so if he has an idea that the
earth is flat or that there's lizard
people that live under the ground like
it's I don't know you got to prove that
that's not real to him if you can't
prove that that's not real and you say
well look at these pictures how that's
[ __ ] they fake you they fake the
moon landing six times yeah you gotta
love that I want to hear his actual
argument but city knows they sit down I
got my filming I wanted to I'll turn the
camera on I'll leave the room I went to
his gym a couple weeks ago and I'd
always heard that he talks a lot at his
gym or kind of goes on about different
appearances things like that yet and I
was totally prepared yeah let's go here
he didn't do anything he didn't barely
even talk we just rolled the whole so
he's probably happy you were there I
wanted to show you some jiu-jitsu
jiu-jitsu wizard he showed me some good
jujitsu
[Applause]